j'ai toujours l'impression d'être chez
moi d'être très sympa d'être intimement
liée aux habitants de la pointe courte
même si je vous dis je ne suis pas de la
famille d'aucun de ces pages peut-être
que d'avoir fait ce film ensemble
ça a créé un lien très particulier
je suis toujours très bien accueilli ce
qu'on va dire et moi je me sens toujours
très bien donc aujourd'hui si je reviens
pour cette semaine deux de mes films à 7
je reviens à la pointe courte ce n'est
pas pour moi a tellement plus
exceptionnelle que l'année dernière où
d'autres fois ça ses origines à sa
sortie le film la pointe-courte fut
qualifié par georges sadoul les
historiens du cinéma d'un des premiers
films de la nouvelle vague est ce qu
avec le recul du temps vous êtes
d'accord avec ce jugement déclarant une
course n'a été fait en 1954 et la
nouvelle vague avec la terre 58 donc
simplement dans les fêtes historiques
c'est un signe précurseur j'étais
peut-être une des premières à dire qu'il
fallait donnait pas cher vite en toute
liberté d'expression essayer de castres
est un petit peu le réalisme des films
de l'époque que je connaissais mal
d'ailleurs mais que je n'ai même pas
bons il la doit avoir résolu sûrement
oui
sur le plan formel aussi sur le plan du
fond l'itinéraire qui nous conduit de la
pointe-courte black panthers peut
paraître assez long assez sinueux si
c'est pas j'essaie de faire des films
comme je les sens où on mange les
tendres se trouve que les hasards de mon
existence de mes déplacements font que
de la pointe cours d'ici à hollywood on
peut penser que c'est un énorme chemin
mais géographiquement c'est vrai mais
autrement
j'ai toujours essayé un peu oui un peu
mais ça a changé pas tellement commun
presque tout le monde est là la route où
c'est moche
ah ouais
là
ben oui moi je me souviens plus comment
rentrer tout à l'heure qu'est ce qui
différencie par exemple ce pêcheur d'un
personnage de black panthers que vous
avez rencontrées et bien la douceur en
face de la violence les certain que la
situation des pêcheurs la pointe courte
qui était grave parce qu'on les embêtait
pour leurs péchés tout ça c'était une
solution c'est de çà fait une solution
le bassin d'épuration et des choses
comme ça mais tandis que le problème des
noirs en amérique c'est un problème
dramatique leur survie mais immédiate le
racisme quand même un problème
dramatique
vous avez dit il ya quelque temps mon
grand regret que mes films sont enfermés
dans une sorte de ghetto intellectuel
alors que je suis sur le public le grand
public pourrait les aimer les apprécier
moi je suis sûr je me vante un peu
peut-être mais je crois que si on
montrait mes films comme un tas d'autres
considérés comme difficiles à tous les
publics
il serait un peu surpris il serait
déboussolés ils seraient quelques fois
des variés comme on dit ici mais
peut-être qui les accepteraient comme
une partie du cinéma parce que même dans
ce qu'on appelle les films commerciaux
il ya des films que le public boude
complètement et les accepte parce que ça
leur est distribué alors à partir du
moment où il ya ça va une imposition
oui mais pas seulement très bien oui là
il ya beaucoup qui est même maintenant
ils veulent bien les foyers soit au
début il voulait pas aller voir les
films parce que c'était trop franches
les morts ça fait plaisir oui maintenant
les plaisirs de moi j'ai vu jouer
oui je le vois jouer quand ils ont passé
leur distribuer 5 ans colisée que sa
femme on est abonné cb qu'est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on parle de cinéma c'est
ça que je vous explique depuis un moment
c'est déphasé c'est pas le cinéma il ya
des fois c'est juste le fait d'avoir
filmé les gens vivent dans un cadre
vivant c'est un rapport humain c'est pas
c'est pas une esthétique alors je veux
bien avoir fait une évolution
personnellement entre mes premiers films
et mai dernier vous comprenez pas ce que
je veux faire un cinéma qui est forme de
cinéma mais il ya une partie du cinéma
qui échappe à toute esthétique à toute
discussion y ont participé et simplement
de regarder dans une boîte exactement
vers la photographie et des choses
livrer des gens qui sont contents de se
retrouver si le mobile non non non non
non ce pinceau numérique le cinéma
souvenez